of course here now is jonathan turley gw
university law professor fox news
contributor uh professor now biden
claims he has the authority
to cancel these student loans citing
this
law and then the covet 19 pandemic
but does he
well it's a little curious of an
argument to cite the heroes act
because they're citing a crisis that in
may
they said had diminished to the point
that they it would change the status of
title 42 on the southern border that
they cited the cdc's view of the
lessening of the crisis
as the basis in court for that argument
it's extremely
dubious uh to
to argue that that act gives the
president the right
to basically toss aside 300 billion
dollars as much as that
in student loans
and you know even if they cour even if
the administration has some success
initially it's going to find a fairly
chilly reception
before the supreme court
which has really been demanding clarity
on these issues not the delegation of
congress to
the executive branches and what's weird
is that these democratic members are
applauding their own institutional
obsolescence i mean
they are all giving these accolades to
the president for circumventing congress
because he knows he couldn't get this
through congress
well pelosi also had something
interesting to say jonathan about this
plan just about a year ago
people think that the president of the
united states has the power
for debt forgiveness
he does not he can postpone
he can delay
but he does not have that power that
would has to be an act of congress
jonathan what changed huh
what changed there
that's inconvenient well you know what's
amazing is what james madison truly
believed that each of the branches would
jealously defend their own authority
that even if this was a member of your
own party in the white house that
members of congress would assert their
institutional rights including that key
power of the purse that is what's so
baffling about the position here
president obama did the same thing he
went to the state of the union and told
congress he was circumventing them
because they wouldn't give him what he
wanted and half of congress on the
democratic side applauded him for
turning them into constitutional
non-entities so i have a you know this
is a really a great stretch the justice
department previously rejected this
basis
for canceling of loans but also the
national the higher education act
makes it very clear that congress can
allow allows for the postponement of
debt but they expect debt to be paid
yeah postponement not cancellation all
you saps who paid off your student loans
years ago don't you feel great tonight
professor good to see you thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else